good afternoon everyone
uh my name is dr angie ambers and i'm
the assistant director of the henry c
lee institute of forensic science in
westhaven connecticut and i'm going to
be talking to you
today about a
post-conviction case in texas a wrongful
conviction for murder
in texas and how we use probabilistic
genotyping
[Music]
to analyze the dna evidence and help
exonerate this individual so
probabilistic genotyping is a
kind of a new tool in our tool set for
forensic dna
analysts and it's really helped to
reduce the subjectivity
in the way that we interpret dna
mixtures in
criminal cases so this
case pertains
to the conviction of a man named lydell
grant
for murder in texas and this is um
lydell when he was arrested for murder
in houston texas
and primarily the evidence that was used
against him during his trial and i'm
going to go through a background
of the case was eyewitness
identification
and flawed dna mixture interpretation
and i say faulty eyewitness
identification because as
anybody that studied criminal justice
and eyewitness identification we know
that it's notoriously unreliable
especially when the the eyewitness
the race or ethnicity of the eyewitness
and the race or ethnicity
of the perpetrator are different and in
this case
the perpetrator lydell is obviously
african-american and the eyewitnesses
for caucasian and then flawed
dna mixture interpretation this is not
the
actual dna mixture that was used in this
case but
for those of you that are not familiar
with what a dna mixture looks like on an
electrophoregram
so this if you look on the far
left hand side of the screen under mr
grant's photo
you see the
the dna locus or dna marker named d3s
1358 that's one of the dna markers that
we analyze
and across the top of this
across the line where d3s 1358 is you
see vwa
d16 csf etc those are the names of the
dna markers tested
and then if you look under each under
each dna marker name
you see several peaks with a number
underneath each peak
and in a single source sample a dna
sample from one individual or from one
person you would only see
two peaks or one peak under each
dna marker because again we are humans
are diploid organisms so we have
two alleles per locus or four mark per
marker that we test
if you have two different alleles at a
particular dna marker you would see
two peaks on the electropherogram
and if you have two of the same alleles
if you're homozygous for that marker
you would see a single allele so
obviously
in this image i'm showing you an example
of a dna mixture there's
far more than two peaks two allele peaks
underneath each dna marker that's tested
and that's because there's more than
one individual dna present in that
mixture
and that this type of scenario of a dna
mixture
is what was part of some of the key
evidence used to convict
mr grant so just a little bit of
background on the case
this is aaron shearhorn he's the
stabbing victim in this case
and the murder again happened in houston
texas
in an area of houston called the
montrose district
and it basically is a like a
nightclub bar restaurant district
in houston and it's particularly well
known
for the for being a club and bar
district for the homosexual community in
houston so when
mr sherhorn was murdered and stabbed to
death in the parking lot outside of this
bar
a lot of you know the media got a hold
of it and of course they were calling it
a hate crime
because of his sexuality in the area of
town
um where he was killed so essentially
um mr sheerhorn had
was not actually inside the club he had
been
out and about in the monto montrose
district that night
uh in december 2010 and he had
encountered an
african-american male they got into a
fight
he had been stabbed multiple times at
that point he got away from the
perpetrator
[Music]
and was running from him and he actually
ran
up to the door of club blur
as you can see in this image and there
were two bouncers standing
at the door and they uh he begged them
he lifted up his shirt
to show the bouncers that he had been
stabbed and he was begging them
to let him inside um for sanctuary you
know to
to be protected because this perpetrator
was still chasing him
the bouncers did not let him inside the
club and
while they were arguing about letting
him in the perpetrator caught up with mr
shearhorn
and proceeded to stab him to death in
the parking
lot of the club and there were several
eyewitnesses that were standing around
in the parking lot
outside of club blur and they witnessed
the stabbing
and i will say that you know one of the
things that
that disturbed me about this case other
than
that this man had clearly been stabbed
in his abdominal area and they wouldn't
let him inside the club for safety
is that there were a half dozen or so
eyewitnesses
that watched his
watched him get stabbed to death
essentially in the parking lot and no
one tried to intervene and help him
nor did they try to detain the attacker
so the attacker ran off and was never
caught they did call 9-1-1 and of course
mr sherhorn died died shortly thereafter
so then how does lydell grant um come
into play here
because i told you that the witnesses
did not
try to detain the perpetrator nor did
they try to help mr sherhorn
so about a week later after the
murder occurred one of those
eyewitnesses
that watched the stabbing was at
a restaurant at a cafe in the montrose
district in houston
and saw our client lydell grant
and thought you know that looks like the
man that i watched stabbed aaron shear
horn in the parking haunted
parking lot of club blur last weekend
so this individual followed
uh lydell grant out into the parking lot
snapped a photo
of his license plate number and then
reported that
to the crime crime stoppers anonymous
tip line
they basically um this individual
basically called crime stoppers and said
one of the eyewitnesses to that murder
that i have that happened in the
montrose district
and i just saw the perpetrator and
here's his license plate number and so
long story short that's how lydell
kind of got intertwined or even on the
radar
of the police for this case
so um after they
put out a warrant for lydell arrested
him
and charged him with the crime or were
in the process of charging him for the
crime
they did a police line up and the
eyewitnesses that watched
the murder occur in the parking lot
outside the club
all of them all six eyewitnesses
identified lydell
as the perpetrator so in addition to the
eyewitness identification
during autopsy during the victim's
autopsy they collected the fingernails
of the murder victim because the
eyewitnesses had said that
he struggled he fought for his life he
was stabbed multiple times
during this altercation and ultimately
as you can see here this is a screenshot
of the dna mixture that was recovered
from the fingernails
of the murder victim during autopsy
and so part of the case was
okay we've got the six eyewitnesses that
have identified
lidell grant as the perpetrator and then
they wanted
the prosecutor wanted to know is the dna
mixture that was recovered from
underneath the fingernails of the murder
victim
is that a mixture of the victim and lido
grant is lydell grant present in that
dna mixture
and this is actually a screenshot of the
final case case file report the dna
summary report
that was used during mr grant's trial in
2011
and item 12.2.1.1
was a swabbing of the murder victims
fingernails
and as you can see they're reporting
that it was a dna mixture
that aaron shearhorn cannot be excluded
as a contributor to the mixture which
you would expect because it was his
fingernails you would expect his dna to
be present
and then they've applied a statistic to
that inclusion
and then of course highlighted in yellow
at the bottom
again this is the final report that was
used during lydell's trial it says
no conclusions will be made regarding
lionel grant as a possible contributor
to this dna mixture
so the analyst the dna expert for the
state in this case
basically said this dna mixture is too
complex
i'm not going to attempt to draw any
conclusions so i'm going to call it
inconclusive
we're not going to say lydell lydell
grant's dna is present
underneath the fingernails of the victim
but we're not going to say he's not
present either we're just going to say
inconclusive the reality
is this is essentially i think
this is the conservative stance that
should have been taken
it should have been an inconclusive
result
um however the way that it was presented
the actual testimony of the expert
during the trial
was a little questionable so when the
prosecutor was asking the dna expert
were you in front of the jury were you
able to
identify lydell grant dean lydell
grant's dna underneath the
fingernails of the murder victim she
said
i wasn't able to do that i called it
inconclusive
inconclusive the dna mixture was too
complex
which was fine but then the prosecutor
went a step further and i'm paraphrasing
some here but it was something to the
effect of oh well you can't say he's not
in there that's
correct and she basically agreed with
that and so it kind of left the door
open
in the minds of the jury that oh well
she's not saying
lidell grant's dna is not there it could
be there
could very well still be there and then
you add that
on top of the fact that there were six
eyewitnesses that testified
and visually identified mr grant and as
you can imagine
that was enough to fail his conviction
so again you've got six eyewitnesses
that are saying
um lidell grant was the man that stabbed
aaron shear horn to death
now at this point um when i'm reviewing
the case vlogs i was the dna consultant
on this case
you know part of me also was wondering
other than
those of us that work in the criminal
justice field know that
eyewitness identification is flawed it's
not very reliable
the other thing that popped into my head
here was you know this was a murder that
occurred in a parking lot of a bar
on a saturday night and so these
eyewitnesses
very likely probably were under the
influence of alcohol so if you tack
if you tack on the um the intoxication
the alcohol intoxication on top of just
the general
unreliability of eyewitness
identification to begin with
you know that's one of the things that
makes this even more
troubling that mr grant was convicted
solely on eyewitness identification by
eyewitnesses that
likely were intoxicated at the time they
were witnessing the crime
so i got involved in this case as a
consultant
in early 2019
so mr grant was convicted again i'll
remind you in 2011
so he had already been in prison for
several years
and during the time that
mr grant was imprisoned there were
there was quite a bit of study being
done
at the federal government level
and by independent group independent
groups of experts
where we were looking into all the
different disciplines in forensic
science and
assessing the reliability and the
validity of the methods that we were
using
in criminal trials and in 2009
actually this was obviously a little bit
before mr grant's conviction
there was a report called strengthening
forensic science in the united states
that path forward
that was published by the national
research council in the national academy
of sciences and it basically kind of was
an
overview of the different disciplines
in the current state of the different
forensic science disciplines and how we
could
improve upon our current methods
and then in 2016 september 2016 there
was a
a pretty influential publication that
came out
it's called the pcast report and pika
stands for
the president's council of advisor on
science and technology
and this was a council of experts that
were put together
scientific experts that were put
together under president obama's
administration
again building upon what the
nrc and national academy of sciences
report said it basically said
you know we've got room for improvement
in our
forensic science methodology and
this pcas report you know it's a pretty
long report but
as far as how it relates to this current
case
one of the areas of weakness
that they identified as far as dna
forensic dna analysis
is in how we interpret forensic dna
mixtures
so the report was basically saying that
our forensic science our forensic dna
technology the instrumentation we're
using
the laboratory methods that we're using
to generate the results
are valid and reliable but
where we could stand for some
improvement is
is in how we interpret the data that we
generated in the laboratory
and so you know i've shown you a
screenshot here one of the statements
from this report was
complex dna mixture analysis
needs additional support to be deemed
scientifically valid and reliable
and you know this was late 2016.
again mr grant's already in prison um
for murder and they just keep this pcast
report keeps getting a lot of press
and so i've highlighted down at the
bottom of the screen here you know this
study aimed to help close the gaps for a
number of what are called forensic
feature comparison methods so again this
report was not just an
overview of the current state of
forensic dna analysis but a lot of
other forensic science methods
like how we compare dna samples bite
marks
latent fingerprints firearms and
ballistics
footwear patterns hair analysis etc
and then right after this pcas report
came out forensic magazine
which is geared towards a lot of
people that maybe aren't working within
the forensic science field but that want
to keep abreast of all the current and
latest developments
yeah they published forensic magazine
published a huge
article that says subjective dna mixture
analysis which has been used in
thousands
of cases across the u.s has been blasted
by a white house panel and again that
white house
panel is that president's council of
advisors on science and technology that
p
cast council and basically
both the pcas report and this particular
article what they said was again
that um when we
as individual trained forensic dna
analysts
try to interpret a dna mixture
that's recovered from a victim or a
crime scene there's some level of
subjectivity that goes into that
analysis and that interpretation and
that we need to find
a better way a more objective way to
analyze these dna mixtures
and one of the suggestions was that we
move
more in the direction of artificial
intelligence
and we allow computers specifically
computer software programs
to analyze these dna mixtures rather
than us
individually as people trying to analyze
these mixtures to
reduce again that subjectivity
so in the in the process of that pcash
report
being developed um remember that report
was published in
late 2016 there were some other things
that were going on as a result of that
2009 nrc report
and one of the things that we were doing
was
auditing forensic science
laboratories criminal crime labs across
the u.s
and kind of assessing how things were
being done in these laboratories and
is it scientifically sound reliable
valid etc
and one of the things that made national
headlines
in april 2015 so about a year before the
pcas report came out
was that there was a big lab in
washington dc
a cream of the crop type lab a high-end
high-level lab that a national
accreditation board
found flaws
in the way that they were interpreting
dna mixtures
and essentially in the bottom right hand
of the screen if you read this
all of these um
[Music]
casework testing that was being done um
by that lab
once this audit was done the lab was
basically shut down and all the case
work was suspended
because what they found was that the
problems with that lab
had centered on the analysis of evidence
that again includes
dna that's from more than one person
and the conclusions regarding the
likelihood that a certain person's dna
is included
in that dna mixture or not so again
we're you know we're further eliminating
as this process is moving along that
there are some
issues with the way we were interpreting
dna mixtures
after this washington dc lab
was shut down and case work
operations were suspended the state of
texas which is where i was working
during this time period
then said whoa you know basically if
if they're doing this incorrectly if
there are weaknesses in the way
dna mixture interpretation is being done
in washington dc i wonder if we have
issues in the state of texas as well so
there was a statewide audit that was
done of all the dna labs
in texas and they wanted to look at you
know
how many cases have already been
adjudicated
and how many current cases do we have
where
a dna mixture is a key part of the
evidence that either
was used in the original conviction or
acquittal or is currently being used for
the
current probate of cases and what they
found
was that there since 1999 and again this
was 2015
there were over 25 000 cases that were
tried in texas courts that involved
dna mixtures and so they actually sent
a letter to all of the all inmates
or maybe they weren't inmates anymore
and they had been released but anyone
that had been convicted
of a crime in texas where a dna mixture
was involved in their conviction
they sent them letters and basically
said this you know we've since
identified that there are issues with
the way
subjectivity issues with the way dna
mixtures are interpreted and this
hence maybe grounds for an appeal for
you or a new trial
and so this was i mean this was huge in
the state of texas again here's another
article um that was published in texas
texas reviewing thousands of dna cases
that used outdated methods for
calculating
odds and again this was august 2016
about a month before the pcas report
came out
again that they were building on um
the washington dc audit and the 2009
nrc report and you know we just realized
with
interpretation comes subjectivity and
anytime there's subject
subjectivity involved in interpreting
a dna mixture we can make errors we can
potentially
you know prosecute the wrong person
convict the wrong person or even
possibly the flip side of that
is acquitting the wrong person
so as far as subjectivity with this big
statewide audit in texas what we found
was that different dna labs across the
state of texas were using different
methods or different approaches to
interpret
dna mixtures to recover from crime
scenes there was
a lack of standardization as far as how
to go about
analyzing and interpreting a dna mixture
the obvious like in murder cases such as
this case
and maybe rape cases there you would
expect the victim's dna to be present in
the mixture and logic would tell you you
can subtract
the known dna profile of the victim out
of the dna mixture
and therefore helped deduce the profile
of the perpetrator that was not
necessarily being done
across the board throughout labs in
texas
and then part of this statewide audit
was to
take complex dna mixture cases from
various labs across the state of texas
and make copies of the dna mixtures that
were used in this trial
disseminate those out to
several different highly qualified dna
analysts
and ask them to independently review and
interpret the mixtures
and what we found was is when you give
the same a copy of the same dna mixture
to several different
highly competent dna analysts many times
the different analysts independently
would come to different conclusions
about whether someone was
included or excluded from that mixture
so um obviously
just just as an example here i'll show
you
one of the things that we were doing
before probabilistic genotyping
is we were doing
interpretation of dna mixtures based on
what we call the
major contributor minor contributor
scenario
where the height of the dna peak in an
electropharogram
is correlated to the amount of dna
present so
in a lot of these cases where you would
expect the victim's dna to be present
under their own fingernails or if it's a
rape case
where it's a vaginal swab you would
expect a lot
of the victim's dna to be present and
therefore the peaks would be higher
and maybe less dna from the perpetrator
would be present
and that would be your minor contributor
and so
if we were looking at a dna mixture we
thought
visually this is a clear major minor
contributor scenario
we were again trying to manually
interpret that mixture
and in this case um if you look at this
slide i've got
marker one so this is showing you an
example of an electro paragraph for four
different dna markers tested
if you look at the two peaks under
marker number one
many analysts would interpret
this as being one person in this dna
mixture
has two copies of allele a
and in under marker three because of the
height of the peak this person has two
copies of allele b
because recall from earlier in this
presentation
that when you have two of the same
alleles that
peak sits on top of each other and it
increases the height of the peak
because there's more copies of that a
little present
um so many analysts would you know
interpret
that part of the mixture on under marker
number four
many analysts would say well the height
of the peaks for allele a and allele d
are higher so that's clearly the major
contributor
and the peak for the allele b and c
under marker four are the minor
contributors so that's how they would
pair the alleles together and
separate the mixture into dna profiles
for two individuals
but you know this can get again when you
when you have multiple different people
looking
at the same dna mixture this can
you can arrive at different conclusions
there's some subjectivity so for the
second marker
many analysts would say okay one
individual in this mixture for this
marker
has an allele a and a we'll see
for marker number three same thing you
know some analysts may say
the major contributor is bb and the
minor contributors
ac for marker four again
a lot of analysts would say there's a
clear major minor contributor there
but then you go back over to the first
marker on the far
left hand side of the screen and even
though most
trained dna analysts would have agreed
that the major contributor in this
scenario
has two copies of allele a
when they were deducing the allele
pairings for the minor contributor
some analysts may say they have two
copies of
the b allele and other analysts may say
well i think they have one copy of the a
allele and one b
and then if you look underneath the
second marker there's several different
scenarios there
that different analysts could arrive at
as far as what the
allele pairings are for the minor
contributor
so and of course keep in mind that in in
standard casework we're analyzing now
20 different dna markers and you're
going to go through this process for
each
marker in the dna profile and so
it's a lot more than just the four
markers that i've shown you on the
screen
in other scenarios so on the previous
slide i was
explaining to you kind of what we
considered in the field a
clear major contributor clear minor
contributor scenario or relatively
straightforward but the reality is
that's not
what a lot of mixtures were looking like
in criminal cases you might
in other words do something like this
where the peak heights are pretty
similar between the peaks for each
marker tested
and so there's no discernible major
minor contributor
so at that point you know and i'll go
back to that slide it gets even
a little more complex in how you're
subjectively
determining which two alleles pair with
which person
for each marker tested so what the
nrc report and the pcash report
basically said
is that we need a better way to do this
we need a better way to
interpret complex dna mixtures and
there's too much subjectivity
involved with people no matter how
well-trained you are how intelligent you
are so let's
let computers do it for it and so
there were software programs developed
to help
interpret complex dna mixtures and need
software programs
do what's called probabilistic
genotyping
where in and i'll go back to this
previous slide
the software programs are looking at
peak heights and various
key components of the electrophilogram
and calculating the probability
of each allele pairing up with another
allele to deduce
the proper what the highest probability
is that
of which allele should be paired
together in this mixture so that you can
deconvolute
the mixture of dna profiles into
separate
individual profiles and two of the
the big probabilistic genotyping
software programs that are currently
being used in casework labs
one is called star mix and the other one
is called true allele
and they both they basically both do the
same thing um
they both are interpreting dna mixtures
based on probabilistic genotyping
um and again it's the less subjective we
can never
completely reduce the subjectivity in
dna mixture interpretation because again
it's a blind process
you know we often say that forensic
science is a historical science because
we are
as analysts we're actually analyzing the
remnants of a crime
we're not actually present when the
crimes being committed when that dna
mixture is being formed so we have to
analyze the data after the fact
and that's what these software programs
do and again
the less objective less subjective
approach is what we were shooting for
because we're
also dealing with some unconscious bias
sometimes with human analysts
but the previous way we were doing it
again involved
calculation of what's called a cpi or
cpe combined
probability of inclusion or combined
probability of
exclusion um we have abandoned that
approach now again and we're using these
computer software programs so we still
have the human dna analyst
that is extracting the dna from the
evidence doing
all of the laboratory work to generate
the dna profiles but once
once the dna mixture profile is
developed and produced
then we're letting a computer software
program analyze the data
instead of us doing it as human so i'll
take you back to
this previous slide in the presentation
where
recall that at the time of mr grant's
original trial in 2011
they had a dna mixture that was
recovered from the fingernails of the
murder victim
and they were not able to draw any
conclusions about whether mr grant was
included or executed from that mixture
so they just called it inconclusive
and so in february 2019 is when i
started consulting on this case and of
course
i'm familiar with the nrc report the
pcash report etc
so i thought okay well maybe you know
this technology was not available to
interpret dna mixtures at the time of
the trial but let's see what these
probabilistic genotyping software
programs will say now
about whether mr grant is included or
exploited from that mixture
so before i sent
the raw data that was originally
generated back in 2011
for probabilistic genotyping analysis i
thought let me just do
kind of a quick screen let me take that
dna mixture
that was produced from the evidence in
2011 and let me just
list the alleles in a basic excel
spreadsheet
and this is what i did so just kind of
at first glance what does it look like
could he be possibly in this mixture
could he not
and you'll see here so on the far left
hand of the screen
you'll see a column called locus that's
the name of the dna marker
that was tested you've got lydell grants
individual dna profile that we obtained
from his reference sample
we've got the in the third column the
victims dna profile
from their reference sample and then
[Music]
the subsequent six columns are the
alleles that were present in that dna
mixture
and what i wanted to see was obviously
is we would expect the victim's dna to
be present in there but is
are there some common alleles with
lionel grant
and what i started seeing was just on
this initial screening
um of course this is not the way we
analyze dna mixtures but this is kind of
a first glance
approach it was pretty obvious to me
that mr grant his dna is not present in
this mixture so everything that's
highlighted in yellow here for you
and in red color
are alleles that were present in the
mixture
that the dna mixture that was recovered
from the victim's fingernails that do
not
correspond to alleles in
the victim's dna profile or mr grant's
dna profile and there were 26
what we call foreign alleles that were
present underneath the murder victim's
fingernails that don't match the murder
victim
or mr grant or the suspect the guy that
was convicted of this crime
so i should point out here that this is
something
that took me about 30 minutes to do
that could have very easily have been
put together
and shown during leidel grant's original
trial in 2011
that i'll point out that lydell grant
was an
indigent client an indigent defendant he
had a
[Music]
public defender defending him and that
public defender did not hire
a forensic dna expert on mr grant's
behalf
so all the jury heard was
what's on this previous slide that there
was a dna mixture recovered
from the murder victim's fingernails and
the dna mixture is too complex we can't
interpret it so we're going to call it
inconclusive
but then of course they heard that there
were six eyewitnesses that identified mr
grant
now with that being said back to this
slide again this took me 30 minutes to
put together
i think even in 2011 before we were
using these
computer software programs to analyze
dna mixtures
had mr grant's attorney hired a dna
expert
this might have and they have tested
this up on the screen
so the jury could see it this might have
planted that
reasonable doubt in the minds of the
jury
that they had the you know the whether
or not they had the correct person
this might might have been enough
to plant that reasonable doubt and
remember the burden of proof in a
criminal trial is you have to think
that someone is guilty beyond a
reasonable doubt there's clearly
someone else present underneath the
fingernails of the murder victim
just by looking at this basic screening
tool so
i was working with mike ware who's the
director of the innocence project of
texas he's a defense attorney so i call
him he's in texas i'm in connecticut
and i send him a screenshot of this and
i'm like well
you know you're right i don't think
lydell is in the mixture
um but what we need to do based on the
current recommendations
of the pcas report and all the national
audits that are happening is we can't
just go with this
we need to now send this raw data
this dna mixture data and have it
analyzed with one of these probabilistic
genotyping software program
so we sent the raw data to a company
called cyber genetics in pennsylvania
and this company is the developer the
maker of true allele
dna interpretation software and what you
can do so this is march of 2019
you can submit the dna data
that that contains the data for the dna
mixture as well as the dna profiles
of the victim and the suspect
and they will run it through their
probabilistic genotyping software and
they will send you back a report
and tell you based on that based on
their software analysis
who's included in the mixture and who's
excluded
and you get it in an email response and
basically you can see here this is
actually a screenshot
of the email that i got back in march
2019 saying
um if you look at the highlighted region
victim aaron shirlhorn's dna was found
on his fingernails well we knew that
because they are
aaron sherhorn's fingernails but the
very next bullet point there you'll
notice
is defendant lidel grant's dna was
not found on the victim's fingernail so
he's
excluded as a contributor to that dna
mixture
and then they go on to state dna from an
unknown person was
found on the victim's fingernails and
they
again subtract the
victim's dna profile out of the mixture
because you know that person's dna
is in the mixture and they essentially
the soccer program essentially deduced
the alleles that are in the dna profile
of the foreign contributor and
um so we got excited at that point we
thought we knew
we were moving in the right direction
and that they had indeed convicted the
wrong person
but on top of the email that you saw in
the previous slide that states
who's included and who's excluded from a
dna mixture
one of the other things that cyber
genetics will do
is they apply a statistical weight
to that inclusion or exclusion and you
can see item 12.2.1.1
is the victim's fingernail we also had
a dna profile from the victim a
reference sample
a victim or i'm sorry a dna profile from
lydell grant the accused
and they apply a statistical probability
so you can see
this is the exponent that 19 underneath
victim
that's the exponent for the statistical
value so you can see
um um this is somewhere between
obviously the victim's dna is included
somewhere up in the quintillion
septillion numbers
he's obviously included we expected that
but look at lydell grant's
reference dna profile he is excluded
um between that billions and trillions
there's 8.5 billion
individuals on planet earth so this
exceeds the popul the human population
of earth
and then the unknown male contributor
who's present in that dna mixture
both the unknown male contributor and
the victim are
determined to be the two individuals in
that mixture they're included in the
mixture
lido grant is excellent so
[Music]
we thought at that point that you know
that was our case that was our grounds
for appeal
you know we've proven that lidell
grant's dna is not underneath the
fingernails of the murder victim
and we contacted the conviction
integrity unit at the houston da's
office
we wanted to move forward with the
appeal
and then the thought process became well
so what
you know um aaron shearhorn was out
in the bar district on a saturday night
in houston
he's a gay man he might have had a
sexual encounter earlier that evening
and that foreign contributor that
unknown
dna profile underneath his fingernails
might not be related to the murder at
all
it might be related to a sexual
encounter that he had
earlier that evening so we knew we had
to find out
[Music]
who this dna profile belonged to
so in april of 2019 we worked with
john donahue at beaufort county
sheriff's office in south carolina
to have a to have this unknown dna
profile
that was found in the mixture searched
against the fbi's codis dna database
and we
got results back a couple of months
later in june 2019 that we had a hit
in the codis database and let me remind
you that
the codis the national dna database
maintained by the fbi
is vastly incomplete because it only
contains the dna profiles of convicted
offenders so people that have been
caught
and it contains for some state it allows
us to
profile the dna of all arrestees so
people that have been arrested but not
yet convicted
so anybody that hasn't been arrested
that hasn't been caught and convicted
will not be in this database so there's
a chance that we could have not
had a hit at all or match in the
database at all
we did get a hit to an individual named
erica carter and
not only had he been in and out of the
prison system throughout his life he's a
habitual criminal
but he was we did some background
investigation on him
he was known to not be incarcerated at
the time mr shearhorn was murdered
he lived in the houston area where he
where mr sherhorn was murdered during
that time period and he moved away
from houston a couple of months after
the crime occurred
he was actually tracked down in december
in atlanta georgia and arrested
for the murder of mr sherhorn and he has
actually confessed to the crime
so june 2019 is when we
identified jericho carter as the
perpetrator
and it took us several more months
after that to get lydell grant out of
prison so this is an
image in the top image
on the far left that's mike ware the
director of the innocence project of
texas
and you can tell lydell is happy in this
photo this was right when he found out
he was going to get released from prison
this was the day before thanksgiving so
late november 2019
and then the bottom photo is him walking
out of the courthouse after he's been
released from prison and that's his
mother and his brother that he is with
and then so that again he was released
from prison the day before thanksgiving
and then december is when they finally
tracked down at this point we were going
to be preparing for a new trial
for lydell so we could present all the
new
dna evidence probabilistic genotyping
analysis
and all the codex hit and everything and
in the meantime the police were
searching for
jamerrica carter that we identified in
the
fbi's database and these are some
screenshots of some articles that came
out
he was arrested new suspect arrested
charged in 2010 montrose stabbing
wanted murder hid in atlanta for years
while an innocent man
sat behind bars and then i just wanted
to show you
an image here um again on the left this
is lydell grant's
mech shot when he was arrested in 2010
and on the far right is jamerrica carter
when he was arrested in december 2019
and you know you can study you can go
back there are
multiple instances throughout history of
where dna has been used to exonerate
someone that was originally convicted
based on eyewitness identification
um and if you end up looking at an
image of the convicted person and the
true perpetrator that was
later convicted there do tend to be some
similarities
in the way they look um
as far as this happening and with
wrongful convictions you can look at the
national registry of
since 1989 there have been
2 611 exonerations
and the combined imprisonment time more
than 23 000
years lost the people that were
wrongfully convicted
and i don't you know i'm not going to
spend a lot of time on all of these
steps but
this graph here talks about
the various contributing factors to
wrongful convictions
and a particularly circled mistaken
witness id which was
a factor in lydell's wrongful conviction
and false or misleading forensic
evidence again
there wasn't false evidence in this it
just was that there was a dna mixture
recovered
and it was called inconclusive and the
way it was presented in court was
misleading and kind of left the door
open
for the jury to interpret
that he possibly could be in the mixture
and then again compounded with the six
eyewitnesses
that identified him that kind of sealed
his state with that conviction
and so i just want to point out here
lastly that
um you know the the nrc the 2009 nrc
report
and the 2016 pcash report
were geared towards they're not
pro-defense reports they are definitely
pro-science for justice reports and our
goal in the justice system whether we
are attorneys
or forensic scientists should be to
find the guilty and protect the innocent
we don't want the
cases like this to happen where someone
spends 10 years in prison
for a crime they didn't commit so
um oops sorry so um
you know we've we've had this mindset we
need to go back to this
there's a 19th century medical legalist
that said you know if the law has made
you a witness
you must remain a man of science you
can't go
into it thinking you have a victim to
avenge or a guilty or innocent person to
convict or save you have to
bear testimony within the limits of
science
um i want to dedicate this
to a lot of people you know they hear
about these cases and they think oh
you're just working for the defense you
were working for
lydell grant the convicted the accused
but
ultimately you know this is a
pro-justice
um stance that we took on this case so
i'd like to dedicate
not just the work that we did to this
case but this presentation
not only to lydell grant who was
wrongfully convicted but also
to mr sheerhorn the victim
because we've finally been able to get
justice for him and his family
and identify the person that really
committed this crime and this was a
joint effort
you know i'm presenting this as a dna
consultant on this case but
i by far did not work by myself on this
and this was a collaborative effort
between myself and again i worked for
the henry lee institute of forensic
science in connecticut
the innocence project of texas and then
the justice through science symbol that
you see here on the screen
is one of the logos for cyber genetics a
company
in pennsylvania that developed
trail software
and again this is mike ware this was the
team
that worked on lydell and mr sherhorn's
behalf to make sure that justice was
done in this case
mike ware again is the director of the
innocence project of texas and he also
runs
the innocence clinic at the texas a m
school of law
and on the far right of your screen is
dr mark purlin
who's the chief scientific officer and
the chief executive
officer of cyber genetics in
pennsylvania and he's one of the
developers
of triol technology which again is
the computer software part one of the
computer software programs that we now
use to analyze complex dna mixtures and
it has greatly reduced
the subjectivity and interpretation
so with that being said thank you very
much for
listening and for attending and have a
good rest of your day
thank you if you have any questions feel
free to reach out